The answer is, the first one can be written as an enhanced for loop. These
other two would require lots of extra counting variables and things to make
them work that way. This one would be difficult to write as an enhanced for
loop because it's using the index i to calculate a value, it's also changing
the values stored in the array. Both of those things are harder to do with an
enhanced for loop. This one would be hard to do with an enhanced for loop,
because it's not actually looking at all of the values in order. It starts at
Index one, and while looking at any one index, it's also looking at the last
index. In an enhanced for loop, you will only get one at a time, and would have
to do some fancy trick to remember the last one that you'd seen. This way is
much simpler.